Al final lo más extraño, sucedió.
El pasado 9 de marzo del 2022
tuvieron lugar las últimas
elecciones presidenciales de Corea del
Sur. Unas elecciones que rompieron toda
una tradición histórica en la
joven democracia surcoreana:
La alternancia de gobierno entre
conservadores y progresistas cada 10 años.
Pero esta vez, queridos amigos, amigas,
las cosas fueron diferentes. Os hemos hablado
ya de ello en Las Claves de la Semana,
el boletín que recibís todos los que formáis
parte de la comunidad de VisualPolitik en Patreon.
Corea del Sur acaba de experimentar todo
un volantazo político. 5 años después los
conservadores regresan al poder. Y no
lo hacen con un candidato cualquiera.
¿Visteis este vídeo?
Ha sido la respuesta a la
victoria de Yoon Seok Yeol
¡Atentos!
[Pero un momento antes de continuar. La
guerra de Ucrania ha hecho que los bancos
centrales de todo el mundo también den un
volantazo monetario. Tras más de una década
de políticas monetarias ultra-expansivas
y enormes programas de gasto público,
la inflación de los países desarrollados ha
escalado hasta su mayor nivel de los últimos
40 años. Esto ha hecho que ahora los bancos
centrales comiencen a tomar cartas en el asunto.
La pregunta es: ¿Hasta dónde escalarán los tipos
de interés? Para responder a esta pregunta no
te pierdas el último vídeo de Si lo Hubiera
Sabido, el canal de información financiera
de Mutuactivos con el que colaboramos.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.]
Dicho esto, arranquemos
Si hace apenas 12 meses le hubieran
dicho a Yoon que un año más tarde
se convertiría en presidente, seguro,
seguro, que se habría echado a reir.
El presidente electo surcoreano es todo
un outsider de la política. Hasta marzo
del 2021 fue el Fiscal General
del país, nombrado por cierto,
por el propio presidente saliente
Moon Jae In. Todo un plot twist.
Como Fiscal General Yoon Seok Yeol fue conocido
por ser implacable contra la corrupción. De hecho
fue el artífice del encarcelamiento de dos
expresidentes surcoreanos, Lee Myung Bak y
Park Geun Hye, que fueron acusados de prácticas
corruptas como sobornos y tráfico de influencia.
Sin embargo, como veremos, eso no fue
lo que le hizo ganar las elecciones.
Una victoria, por cierto, lograda por un
estrechisimo margen: el 48,56% de los votos frente
al 47,83% de su contrincante progresista. Menos de
un punto de diferencia, menos de 250.000 votos.)
Ahora bien, ¿Qué explica que se haya roto
la histórica alternancia de gobierno cada
10 años? ¿Por qué Moon Jae In
se ha convertido en el primer
presidente cuyo partido no ha renovado
la confianza de los surcoreanos tras
el primer mandato?¿Qué futuro se
avecina en la Península de Corea?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(LA HERENCIA DE MOON)
Moon Jae In se presentó a las elecciones
de 2017 con una serie de promesas quizás
demasiado grandilocuentes y
arriesgadas para un mandato
de cinco años. Recordad que en Corea del
Sur no existe la reelección presidencial.
(Moon prometió llevar a cabo una completa
renovación social, económica y política que,
por ejemplo, incluía terminar de una vez
por todas con las estrechas conexiones entre
la política y los chaebol - los grandes
conglomerados empresariales surcoreanos.
También prometió trasladar la
oficina del presidente fuera de Seúl,
terminar con la energía nuclear civil
y, las dos cosas más importantes,
solucionar el grave problema de los
precios de la vivienda que hay en Seúl
y su área metropolitana y conseguir de una
vez por todas la paz con Corea del Norte.)
Pues bien, 5 años después, ninguno
de estos grandes objetivos se había
cumplido totalmente. Incluso, podríamos decir,
que teniendo en cuenta sus propias
expectativas su gobierno ha sido un fracaso.
Ni siquiera logró cumplir una promesa menor como
es trasladar la oficina del presidente fuera
de Seúl. Algo que por cierto ahora su propio
partido le echa en cara al nuevo presidente.
[Cosas de la política.]
. (Yoon y Moon chocan por el traslado de la
oficina presidencial - Korea JoongAng Daily
Los legisladores del PD en la reunión cuestionaron
la prisa y algunos insinuaron que Yoon podría
tener razones no reveladas para no querer
mudarse a la Casa Azul, como el feng shui.)
Claro que esta es la cuestión más anecdótica.
En el caso de la política energética, por ejemplo,
mucho más trascendente, en 2017 nada más llegar al
poder Moon Jae In anunció un plan para eliminar
progresivamente la energía nuclear del país.
(Junio 2017: Terminaremos con el plan de
generación de energía nuclear y allanaremos
el camino para una era libre de energía nuclear.
[...] Cancelaremos los planes existentes para
construir nuevas plantas y no extenderemos la vida
útil de las centrales nucleares". - Moon Jae In)
[Suspiro profundo] Qué mal
envejecen algunas hemerotecas…
Porque, claro, con los altísimos
precios del gas natural y el
petróleo y con el carbón también por las
nubes, las cosas cambiaron radicalmente.
El propio gobierno de Moon de repente
pareció abanderar la campaña pronuclear.
(El ministro de comercio y energía
de Corea del Sur visitó la central
nuclear de Hanul en la región de Gangwon
[...] y pidió que se completen rápidamente
los reactores nucleares en construcción,
sugiriendo una relajación en la política
de eliminación gradual de la energía
nuclear frente al aumento vertiginoso
de los precios del combustible. - Pulse News)
Que sí, que rectificar es de sabios… Pero, no se,
¿en solo 5 años y después de ser tan categóricos?
Que reconozcan entonces que estaban equivocados.
Pero, esperad, porque no
hemos hecho más que empezar.
Por ejemplo, es cierto que su política hacía
Corea del Norte ha supuesto el mayor periodo
de estabilidad militar en la península de
Corea desde la Sunshine Policy de finales
de los años 90, pero al final, salvo por sus
tres cumbres con Kim Jong Un y las dos de Trump,
en las que actuó como mediador, los
resultados no han ido mucho más allá.
¿Habéis visto el vídeo, no? Pues.. Eso.
(Durante la presidencia de Moon Jae In, Corea
del Norte continuó su campaña de provocaciones
constantes. Por ejemplo, Pyongyang lanzó decenas
de misiles de diverso rango, continuó insultando
a las autoridades del Sur en sus medios estatales
e incluso pocos meses después de llegar Moon al
poder probaron una bomba atómica de hidrógeno.
Eso sí, esto último, las pruebas nucleares, sí
que se han detenido en seco. La península de
Corea lleva cuatro años y medio sin ver
una sola detonación nuclear. Claro que,
también puede ser que simplemente esa fase del
programa atómico norteño ya fuera completada.
La guinda del pastel se vivió en junio de 2020,
cuándo Corea del Norte hizo saltar
por los aires, ojo, de forma literal,
la Oficina de Enlace Intercoreana de Kaeseong
, un símbolo del diálogo entre
las dos Coreas. Desde entonces, los progresos
diplomáticos entre ambas Coreas se congelaron.)
Por supuesto, a pesar de sus promesas,
Moon no logró cerrar un acuerdo de paz
que formalmente ponga fin de una
vez por todas a la Guerra de Corea.
Porque sí, para los que no lo sepáis, la guerra de
Corea no terminó oficialmente en 1953. Ese año se
firmó un simple armisticio, un alto fuego. Así que
técnicamente los dos países continúan en guerra.
Pues bien, el caso es que a pesar de sus promesas
Moon tampoco consiguió ese tanto diplomático.
[Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Casi que mejor. Mejor no imaginar
las concesiones que hubiera tenido
que hacer para conseguir ese papel.]
Por último, para concluir esta lista de grandes
fracasos políticos o promesas no cumplidas,
tenemos quizás la cuestión qué
más ha pesado en la derrota del
candidato oficialista: la política de vivienda.
Un tema sobre el que ya os hablamos
aquí en VisualPolitik. Desde entonces
hasta las elecciones pasaron unos 2 años y las
cosas no solo no mejoraron sino que
no hicieron más que empeorar. Fijaos.
El precio medio de la vivienda en Seúl, que
es el área más tensionada, se ha incrementado
un 35% desde que Moon Jae In
llegó al poder, y alrededor de un 50% desde 2015.
En algunas zonas de la ciudad
se han más que duplicado!
Para que os hagáis una idea, esto supone que
un surcoreano que se quiera comprar hoy un
apartamento normal de unos 82 metros cuadrados en
Seúl tendrá que apoquinar de media más de 970.000
dólares, cuando solo tres años antes, en 2017, ese
mismo apartamento le hubiera costado unos 590.000.
Así que claro, noticias como esta,
no resultan nada sorprendente.
(Moon admite el fracaso de su política
de vivienda - The Korea Herald)
Bueno, al menos en este caso si
lo han admitido. Algo es algo.
Como os podéis imaginar, esto ha
decepcionado muchísimo a la gente
joven que confió fervientemente
en Moon en 2017. Quizás no os
acordéis pero se le describía
casi como el Obama surcoreano.
Desde luego, en VisualPolitik no nos
ha sorprendido nada lo ocurrido. La
mayor parte de las medidas que tomó Moon
estaban dirigidas a limitar la demanda
y muy pocas a incrementar la oferta de viviendas.
Pues bien, estos han sido en definitiva
los grandes errores que han terminado
provocando un cambio de rumbo histórico en
Corea del Sur. Un cambio de rumbo, eso sí,
que ha llegado por los pelos y, la verdad, con
poco entusiasmo por parte de los surcoreanos.
Todo sea dicho.
Pero ahora la cuestión que podemos,
qué tenemos que plantearnos es:
¿Qué planes tiene Yoon Seok
Yeol para Corea del Sur?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(LA ‘ERA YOON’: ¿QUÉ LE ESPERA A COREA?)
La victoria por la mínima de Yoon Seok
Yeol amenaza con convertirse en todo un
torbellino para la política surcoreana. Para la
política interna pero también para la exterior.
Y es que si hay algo que caracteriza
a Yoon es precisamente que se trata de
un personaje peculiar. Muy pero que muy peculiar.
( Yoon Seok Yeol se declara abiertamente
anti-feminista y en la campaña le gustaba
jactarse de ello. También pertenece a la
congregación cristiana protestante de la Yeouido
Full Gospel Church. Hablamos de una congregación
religiosa de unos 800.000 miembros que es una de
las más conservadoras de Corea, y cuyos líderes
encabezan los movimientos anti-LGTB en el país.
Por otro lado, el ex-Fiscal
General es, en lo económico,
seguidor de las teorías de Mises y Friedman
en cuanto a la defensa del libre mercado. Es
un firme partidario de la desregulación y
los impuestos bajos. Y de hecho, se espera
que ponga al mando de la economía del país a un
perfil técnico que sea próximo a estas ideas.)
Pero, concretemos un poco más todo esto. Ya os
hemos contado cuáles han sido los principales
factores que han contribuido a la derrota
del oficialismo tras la presidencia de Moon.
Así que ahora la pregunta es: cuáles
son exactamente las propuestas del
nuevo presidente para afrontar todos esos retos?
Pues bien, una de las políticas más ha defendido
durante la su campaña fue la de apostar de nuevo
por la energía nuclear. Si, el gobierno de Moon
canceló la construcción de varios reactores,
ahora el nuevo presidente considera que
la energía de los átomos es la mejor
forma de hacer que Corea Sur consiga durante
décadas energía abundante, limpia y barata.
De hecho, cuándo nombró su panel de expertos
del comité para la transición presidencial se
pudieron ver varios nombres de expertos en energía
nuclear. Toda una declaración de intenciones.
(Respecto a la vivienda, otra de las
grandes preocupaciones sociales del país,
Yook se ha comprometido a impulsar
la colaboración público-privada para
construir 2 millones y medio de
viviendas en todo el país durante
sus cinco años de mandato. De todas
ellas 1,3 millones estarán en Seúl.
Eso por el lado de la oferta. Por
el lado fiscal Yoon dice que hará
justo lo contrario de lo que ha hecho
Moon: aliviará las restricciones a las
hipotecas y reducirá el impuesto
sobre las ganancias de capital.
También ha propuesto revisar el impuesto
de bienes inmuebles para los propietarios
múltiples para así reducir con
ello el precio de los alquileres.)
Este es un tema que en Corea últimamente
acapara toda la atención. Pensad que según
la Confederación Coreana de Sindicatos, un
surcoreano medio de 20 años tardaría de media
un siglo en terminar de pagar por sí solo un
apartamento normal en Seúl. ¡Todo un siglo!
De hecho, según una encuesta de The
Herald Business y el Instituto de
Opinión de la Sociedad Coreana,
1 de cada 4 votantes cree que
la estabilidad del mercado inmobiliario
es el mayor reto del nuevo presidente.
Pero aquí no termina todo. Corea es un país
con una política exterior complicada. El
gobierno coreano tiene que lidiar con su
vecino comunista del norte y un delicado
equilibrio en las relaciones con
China, Japón y Estados Unidos.
Un equilibrio que no pocas veces se
convierte en todo un quebradero de cabeza.
Pues bien, todo apunta a que el próximo gobierno
dará un bandazo en su política exterior
para volverse más pro-Estados Unidos y
también pro-Japón. Lo que evidentemente
puede enfriar algo las cosas con China.
Sin ir más lejos, el nuevo
presidente defiende cosas
como aumentar las baterías antimisiles
THAAD estadounidenses. Un despliegue que
ya le costó a Corea sufrir todo un boicot
comercial y turístico por parte de China.
(“Reconstruiré la alianza Corea-Estados Unidos
y fortaleceré la alianza estratégica integral,
al tiempo que compartiremos los valores
fundamentales de la democracia liberal,
una economía de mercado y los derechos humanos.
Desarrollaré relaciones bilaterales de respeto
mutuo entre Corea y China y crearé una relación
Corea-Japón orientada al futuro.” - Yoon Seok Yeo)
Pero vale, a estas alturas del vídeo
ya sé lo que muchos estáis pensando:
¿Y qué demonios pasa con Corea del Norte?
Pues… ¿Os recuerdo la reacción de Pyongyang?
Como todos los presidentes conservadores,
Yoon es partidario de volver a la línea
dura con Pyongyang. En este caso, incluso
es partidario de intentar que Estados Unidos
despliegue más armas estratégicas en Corea.
Claro que también ha dejado claro que está
dispuesto a continuar con los diálogos de paz.
La verdad, es que haga lo que haga, lo más
probable es que veamos constantes tiras y aflojas
entre las dos Coreas, que, por otra parte, es lo
que ya viene siendo habitual desde hace décadas.
O quizás no, quién sabe, en Corea el grado
de imprevisibilidad es siempre bastante alto.
Por último, si os parece, echemos un
vistazo a las medidas económicas que
el nuevo presidente ha prometido. Las medidas con
las que espera que Corea del Sur recupere
la vitalidad económica que tenía antaño.
Atentos.
(Yoon ha anunciado
una lucha sin cuartel contra la inflación,
reducir la burocracia en la economía con
hasta 80 regulaciones menos para las empresas,
y flexibilizar el mercado laboral, por ejemplo,
para que los trabajadores puedan trabajar más
horas extras, algo que limitó el gobierno de Moon.
También ha prometido colaborar con
Samsung Electronics para estrechar la
brecha que actualmente esta empresa tiene con
la taiwanesa TSMC, el mayor fabricante mundial
de semiconductores. Esto es algo que el nuevo
presidente considera estratégico tanto desde
el punto de vista económico como desde el
punto de vista de la seguridad nacional.)
Ya os hemos contado tanto en pasados
vídeos como en boletines de patreon,
los semiconductores son algo así como el
santo grial para las economías de Taiwán
y de Corea, y en general para las
tecnologías avanzadas del siglo XXI.
Y ya, a partir de este punto, en las cuestiones
restantes, los planes de Yoon son de momento
poco claros. Así que aquí en VisualPolitik
estaremos particularmente atentos a cómo se
desarrolla este aparente volantazo político
con el que Corea del Sur ha pasado de tener
un presidente al que comparaban con Obama
a otro que comparan con Ronald Reagan.
Solo el tiempo nos podrá decir si
realmente esto es o no una exageración.
De momento, turno para ti: ¿Con lo que has
visto crees que el nuevo presidente podrá
corregir los principales problemas de Corea?
¿Vivirá Corea del Sur una especie de renacer
económico tal y como vaticina Yoon? ¿Qué sucederá
con las relaciones con China y Corea del norte?
Déjanos tu comentario aquí abajo y, si te ha
gustado este vídeo no olvides darle a like
y suscribirte a VisualPolitik para no perderte
ninguna de las novedades que están por llegar.
Una vez más, gracias por estar
ahí. Un saludo y hasta la próxima.